okay hi everyone back from all cs224n um okay so for today the plan is essentially a continuation of what we started on Tuesday so I'm going to say um more about language models and more about rnns in particular introd using a more advanced form of recurrent new network which was for a while very dominant um lstms will talk about those and then in the latter part as something to be done with um current neural networks we'll start looking at neural machine translation um okay so on Tuesday what we did was we
introduced language models A system that predicts the next word and then I introduced recurrent new Networks that's was this new neural architecture that can take sequential input of any length and it applied the same weight to each step and can optionally produce output on each step um so these are two distinct Notions though they tend to go together so uh recurrent new network can be used for other purposes on any kinds of sequence and I'll mention a few of those later today um and language
modeling is a traditional component of many NLP tasks anything to do with generating text or estimating likelihoods of pieces of text and indeed in the modern instantiation of large language models essentially everything we do in um NLP is being done by language models so a language model one way to do it is with the recurrent neural network it's certainly not the only way we also talked last time about engram language models which were language models and then starting next week we'll start to talk about
Transformers which are now the most widespread way that's used for building language models um so just finish off a teeny bit that I didn't get to last time on evaluating language models well one way to evaluate language models is what I did in class last time generate some text and say hey doesn't this text look good um but you know often we want something more rigorous than that and the standard way to evaluate language models is to say well you know a language model scores a piece of text
and says How likely it is and our standard for text in the language is stuff produced by human beings so if we find a new piece of text which wasn't text that the model was trained on right we want some fresh um fresh evaluation data and we show it um to a language model model we can then ask the language model to predict the success of words of this text and the better it is at doing that the better a language model it is because it's more accurately able to predict um a human written piece of text
and so the standard way that that is measured is with this measure that's called perplexity and so for perplexity we are taking um the probability of a prediction from the language model we're in inverting it so instead of it being you know .002 or something we're turning into 500 or something like that um and then we're taking those numbers we're taking the product of them at each position in the text and then we're finding the geometric average of them um so that's the measure that's normally
used but if we in this class we've been tending um to look um at um negative log likelihoods and um the idea of cross entropy um and so what perplexity is is it's just the exponential of the Cross entropy um so if you've already familiar with negative log like per word negative log likelihoods if you just exponentiate that um you then get the perplexity now there's one other little trick as to what base you use for your logarithms and exponentials I mean traditionally thinking of sort of binary and stuff a
lot of the time people use Bas two for measuring perplexity um that's kind of gone out now a lot of the time now people are using natural logs but if you're comparing perplexity numbers they're going to be different depending on um what base you're using for things so you needs to be aware of this um so from a sort of a modern perspective it kind of makes no sense um why um perplexity is used um the story of why perplexity was used was you know in the bad old days of symbolic artificial
intelligence when all of those famous people like John McCarthy and Ed Fen bam were around doing logical based systems um some people then essentially at IBM including Fred gelan started exploring probabilistic methods for speech recognition and other similar methods um and um the story Fred gelene used to tell was well at that time this was in the late 70s or early 80s that none of the AI people um that he was trying to talk to understood how to do any real math and didn't understand um any
information Theory Notions of um of do doing things like cross entropy or cross entropy rate so he had to come up with something simpler they could understand um and so what he came up with is by sort of doing this exponentiated um perplexity you can think of per a perplexity number as being equivalent to how many uniform choices you're choosing between so if the perplexity of something is 64 that's like having a 64 sided dice that you're rolling each time and that's your chance of your chance of getting a
one on that is your chance of guessing the right word um so that was why perplexity got introduced but it's kind of stuck and so when you see scores for language models you generally still see perplexities so a lower perplexity is better um so here are the kind of numbers and where progress was made with neural language models so before that um people used engram language models and people used clever ways to smooth them using methods I vaguely alluded to last time of this ad case smoothing and doing
back off actually people use clever methods um around um the 2000th decade the cleverest method known of smoothing engram language models was this thing called interpolated kessi smoothing um and so for a big language model using that the perplexity was about 67 um which in some sense means that you weren't very good at predicting the next word um but you know that had actually been enormous progress you know when I was a young person doing um NLP you know perplexities were three figure numbers
right you were commonly seeing you know perplexities of 150 or something like that so progress was made um so when rnn's were first introduced people weren't really actually able to do better with a sort of a pure RNN but they could do better by combining an RNN with something else such as a symbolic maximum entropy model which I'm not going to explain but those are numbers like that 51 but where progress um really started to be made was when lstm started to be used as an improved RNN
which is what I'm going to come to next so here are some lstm models and now you're getting numbers like 43 and 30 and so for 30 you've sort of halfed the perplexity which in um cross entropy terms means you reduce the cross entropy by about one bit um and so you've made real progress um in your language modeling Now by modern standards um these numbers are still really high right for the best language models that we have now you're getting perplexities in the single digits you're getting
models that are very often able to guess exactly the right word though of course not always cuz no one can predict what words going to be said by someone next in a lot of circumstances okay um so um to motivate lstms then wanted to sort of say a bit about how there are problems with rnns and why that motivated fixing things and these are the problems of Vanishing and exploding gradients so what we wanted to do was say okay we've tried to predict a word at position four and often we're going to get it we're not going to
predict it with 100% probability so we we have a loss that's a negative log likelihood we give to that word and we're going to want to back propagate that loss um through the sequence um and work out our gradients as we always do now just one note about something someone asked after class um last time you know I sort of showed it back propagating the whole sequence but we're doing this at every time step right so we're going to back propagate a loss from time step two back propagate a
loss from time step 3 4 5 6 7 we're doing it for each one and in one of the slides last time we then discussed how we're going to sum all of those losses or work out the average loss um but for doing this one when we back propagate this loss what happens well what happens is we're going to do the same kind of chain roll where we're multiplying these partial derivatives at every time step and well here we've only got a few of them but you know maybe we're going to have a sequence 30 long
and so we're going to be multiplying each time the partial of HK time with respect to the partial of HK minus1 and so what kind of effect is that going to have um in particular you know we might ask what happens if these are small or what happens if these are large well if they're small the gradient will gradually get smaller and smaller and disappear as we back propagate it along the sequence yeah so why we're taking partial J over partial should we take partial J sure I mean we're doing that as well um
but you know in general we have to walk the partials along and then you know we then have a w at the next step I mean if we're thinking of the sort of computation graph that we're sort of doing the chain rule backwards along we're going to be going through a w at each step and then arriving at another AG right um yeah so I mean at this point you can you can do some math and thinking about things um and there's a couple of papers that are mentioned at the bottom here which I'm actually uh rushing ahead not
going to do very carefully um but the point is that if you're taking the partial of HT with respect to HT minus1 um and if you make a simplifying assumption and say Suppose there isn't a nonlinearity suppose Sigma is just the identity then what the partial will be is the Matrix wh and so if you keep on back propagating along the recurrent neural network what you're going to be doing is what ending up with powers of the Matrix wh and then there's the question of what happens when you raise that
Matrix to higher and higher Powers well at that point you can represent the Matrix in terms of its igen vectors and IG values and then there are two possibilities either all the igen values are less than one and that means that that number will be getting smaller and smaller smaller as you raise it to higher power or it can have IG ve IG values that are larger than one and then things will get bigger and bigger as you go further back so essentially as you back propagate the gradients backwards unless things are sort of just
precisely of um corresponding to a largest Aon Vector of large ion value of approximately one you're either going to get a Vanishing or an explosion and both of those will be kind of bad so why is Vanishing gradient a problem I mean in a sense you could think it's it's not a problem it's what should be happening because all else being equal you know the closest words are the most relevant ones and so that's where you should be updating your parameters the most and to some extent
that that's true but nevertheless this vanish gradient in this model happens much too severely so that if you're looking at the loss from a later position and comparing it to the loss um from an earlier position and then you're seeing how things are updating it's sort of primarily the update is being determined by the very nearby loss and not by the far away loss um that the gradient signal from far away is much much smaller ER and well that's bad because you know overall for language
modeling there are lots of cases where we want to be able to transmit signals a long distance so here's my piece of text um when she tried to print her ticket she found that the printer was out of toner she went to the stationary store to buy more toner it was very overpriced after installing the toner into the printer she finally printed her yeah so you know human being you know it's obvious we can predict this with pretty much probability one you know so um really low perplexity for making this decision um but you know if
you're that's depends on getting back to the tickets which are sort of about 20 odd words back right if you're just seeing installing the toner into the printer she finally printed her could be anything it could be her paper her invitation her novel um lots of things could be you're certainly not going to guess tickets so we sort of want to have these really long distance dependencies but we're only going to be able to learn these long distance dependencies if we're actually getting sufficient signal
between that position and when the word tickets appears near the beginning that we can learn the fact that having that tickets 20 words back is the good predictive thing for predicting tickets here and what we find is um that you know when the gradient becomes very small the RNN doesn't learn these kind of longdistance dependencies and so it's unable to sort of make these predictions well at test time I mean this is a very sort of just rough uh back of the envelope estimate but you know what people actually found
is that you know with this the kind of simple r&n that we've introduced up until now that the amount of effective conditioning you could get was about seven tokens back um that if things were further back than that it just never learned to condition on them and so you know compared to when we were talking about NS and I said are usually the maximum people did was 5 G occasionally a bit bigger because of the fact that there was this exponential blowout although in theory we've now got a much
better solution in practice because of Vanishing gradients well we're only kind of getting the equivalent of 8 G so we haven't made that much progress it feels like um so there's a reverse problem which can also happen of exploding gradients so if the gradient becomes very large because the IG values of that Matrix are large well what we're doing for the parameter update is you know we've got a learning rate but essentially if the gradient is very large we're going to make a very very
large parameter update and that can cause very bad updates because you know we're sort of assuming that we're taking a step in the direction of the gradient and well we might overshoot a little but we'll be in a roughly in the right Zone but you know if we had an enormously exploded gradi and well we could kind of be sort of walking off anywhere and you know we think we're heading to the sieras and we end up in Iowa or something like that right you know that we could just go arbitrarily far and
where we're ending up it might not be making any progress whatsoever um so exploding gradients are a problem um they can also cause Infinities and nans and they're always a problem when you're training models um now for for dealing with exploding gradients um this is the accepted wisdom um this unfortunately doesn't this isn't High futing math really um what people use for exploding gradients is a crude hack they clip gradients um but you know it works really well and you really want to
know about this um because clipping gradients is often essential um to having newal networks not having problems so what we do for gradient clipping is we work out the norm of the gradient and if it seems too large and that varies but you know that's normally 5 10 20 something like that for a norm of a gradient is seen as the limit of what's okay if the norm of your gradient is too large you just scale it down in every direction and you apply a smaller gradient update um it works um yeah so that
problem is solvable um but fixing the vanishing gradient seemed a more difficult problem right that this was the problem that our rnns effectively couldn't preserve information over many time steps um and well what seemed to be the problem there the problem seems to be really that we've got sort of an architecture that makes it very hard to preserve information so if we look at sort of the Hidden state from one time step to the next time step um it's completely being Rewritten right so
we're taking the previous time steps hidden um hidden Vector we're multiplying it by a matrix which completely changes it in general adding in other stuff from the input so if we just like to say we'd like to say we'd like you to carry forward information there's useful stuff in htus y can you just kind of keep it around for a while it's not actually very easy to do in this formulation cuz you know trying to learn uh W vectors that all mostly preserve what was there before isn't at all and
obvious thing to do um so the question was could we design an RNN which had a sort of a memory where is easy to preserve information yes so in in one of the earlier slides you mentioned the exponentiation happened during their analysis they remove the larity so sort ofation prevent Vanishing oring no it actually doesn't I mean you can make an argument that it should help because you've got effectively if you got something like tan H you've got a flattening function um so it should help
somewhat but it doesn't solve it even if you're using a t nonlinearity well so I guess it should sorry it should help with exploding though actually that even that still happens but it definitely doesn't help with the vanishing if you have Sig think that is one value so you're always pushing the value between one so it's not going up or going down it's staying between Z and one but so yeah Z well I guess would it go up and so you have a really small value that becomes oneus a really small value Sig *
1us oh Sig * okay um yeah so can we have a different architecture so we have a memory that you can add to um and so that led into this new kind of newal network the lstm so this is going back a few years but any rate um this was trying to improve Siri suggestions and the big breakthrough that they were described was being described was oh we're now using an lstm in the keyboard prediction and the whole advantage of that um was was going to be able to predict context further back so you could differentiate between the children
are playing in the park versus the Orioles are playing in the playoff okay um so so the sort of big thing that was seen as very successful was these um lstms long short-term memory um just to say a little bit of the history here right um just on the how to PA this name right that I think people often don't even understand it right so what you wanting to do was model shortterm memory right because so for humans people this normally distinguish between the short-term memory of stuff that you heard recently
versus things that you permanently stored away um and the suggestion was well in short-term memory humans can remember stuff for quite a while right you know if you're having a conversation you can still remember um the thing that the person said a few turns ago the conversation said bring back up of oh didn't you say they um took last weekend off or something right and well the problem was that the simple rnns their short-term memory was only about seven tokens and so we'd like to make it
better than that and so we wanted long short-term memory and that's where this um name came about and so this was a type of recurrent new network um that was um um proposed by HW and schmidhuber in 1997 as a solution to the problem I mean there's actually a second relevant piece of work that came a few years later that you know that first paper is the one that everybody cites um but there's then a second paper by gz and smid Huber in 2000 which actually introduces a crucial part of the lstm as
we've used in the 21st century that wasn't in the original paper um and you know so it's sort of an interesting story of all of this so you know that um joggen schmidhuber and his students did a lot of really crucial foundational work in newal networks and the sort of these years and the lat years of the '90s um when just about everybody else had given up on newal networks um so unlike these days where you know doing um pioneering work in new networks is a really good way to get
yourself hugely compensated jobs at Google meta or open AI it really wasn't actually in these days so you know if you um ask G what happened to these students um of hot crater and um G um that both of them are still in Academia but um G seem to give up on AI and new networks all together and does stuff in the area of multimedia um and SE Haw riter um is still in machine learning but you know for quite a long time he sort of basically gave up on doing more General neural network stuff and went into
bioinformatics so if you look at his Publications from about 2 2015 um they were all in bioinformatics and most of them weren't using neural networks at all um though um kind of nicely I mean he's actually gone back into new networks more recently and is publishing a new networks again um yeah so um really not much attention was paid to this work at the time and so it only sort of really kind of gradually seeped out further um so um Schmid hu had a later student in the mid 2000s decade Alex Graves um and Alex Graves um did
more stuff with lstms and for people who've seen um speech recognition where people commonly do CTC loss and decoding Alex Graves invented that but um most crucially um Alex Graves then um went to um Toronto to be postto for Jeff Hinton and that sort of brought more attention to the fact that lstms were a good model um and then Jeff Hinton went to Google in 2013 and That Was Then sort of the use of um lstms at Google um in the sort of 2014 to 16 period was when they really sort of um hit the world and became for
a while the completely dominant framework people use for neural networks um in the world of uh I guess startups this is what you call being too early for the first people um yeah um okay long short-term memories back to the science um so um let's see um there's a slide here that talks about um long short-term memories but maybe I'll just sort of skip straight ahead and start to show the pictures so we've still got a sequence of inputs XT and the difference now is um inside our newal Network we're going to have two
hidden things one that's still called The Hidden State and the other one that's referred to as the cell State and so what we're going to do is we're going to modulate how these things get updated by introducing the idea of gates and so gates are calculated things vectors whose values are probabilities between zero and one and they're things that we're going to use to sort of turn things on or shut them off in a probabilistic way so we're going to control the movement of information by
having gating and so we're going to calculate three gating vectors so these vectors are the same length as our hidden States um and so the way we calculate these gating vectors is with an equation that looks basically exactly the same as what we were using for current newal networks um apart from the Sigma there is definitely going to be the logistic that goes between Zer and one so we get probabilities and the three gates we're going to calculate is a forget gate which is going to say how much do we
remember of the previous times hidden State I think the forget gate was actually wrongly named I think it makes more sense to think of it as a remember gate because it's actually calculating how much you're remembering um okay then we've got an input gate and the input gate is going to say how much are you going to pay attention to the next input the next XI and put it into your hidden State and then you have an output gate and the output gate is going to control how much of of what's in the cell which
is your primary memory are you going to transfer over to the hidden state of the network okay so once we have um once we have those Gates um what we're then going to do has have these equations which are how we're going to um sort of update things so the first thing we're going to do is work out uh work out a potential new cell content so the new cell content is going to be calculated exactly using the exactly the same kind of equation we saw last time for a current networks we're
going to have um these two matrices um the cell W and the cell U and we're going to multiply one by the last time's hidden State and the other by the new input add on a bias and that's a potential update to the cell but then how we're actually going to update the cell is by making use of our gates so we're going to say the new cells content is going to be the old cells content um hadamar producted with the forget gate so that's how much to remember of the previous cells content plus this
calculated update had aad producted with the input gate how much to pay attention to this new potential update that we've um invented and then for calculating the new hidden State that's going to be um the had mod product between the output gate and um our CT having been put through a tan H um and you know one idea here is you know we're thinking about how much to keep on remembering what we've had in the past but you know for thinking about sort of only sending some information to
the hidden State as sort of a way to start thinking about that is you know the hidden state of a recurrent newal network is sort of doing multiple Duty right like on one part of it is we were going to feed it into the output to predict the next token but in another thing it's going to do is we just want it to store information about the past that might come in useful later and that we'd like to kind of have carried through the sequence and so really only some of what in the hidden State we want to be using
to predict the current word some of it isn't relevant to predicting the current word but would be good stuff to know for the future right so you know if the previous words were set in um for predicting the next word we basically just need to know we're in a satin context where the or a will come next but you know if earlier on the sentence that been saying the King of Prussia we somewhere in the hidden State we want to be keeping the information that there's a King of Prussia because that might be
relevant for predicting future words and so it makes sense that we only want to have some of what's in our memory being used to predict the the next word in the current context so the cell is our long short-term memory and then we're moving over to the hidden state things are going to be relevant for Generation um yeah I've sort of said that okay uh all these are vectors of the same length n yeah so all of all of these things both the gates and the new values for the cell and hidden state they're
all vectors of length n and part of how things actually get convenient when you're actually running of these is up until here all of these things have exactly the same shape so you can actually put them all together into a big Matrix and do the computations of all four of these in terms of um one big Matrix if you want question if you did not have the Dage activation in the hidden State update then the output dat should have been expressed by both the input dates and you're if this if this bit wasn't
here then then you would not need an output dat well because ft and it would have been able to express it account for it in some sense my question is how much does having right well no to the extent that you want to mask out part of what's in the cell so it's not visible when you're generating the next token isn't it still useful to have an output gate you can essentially have XT C you don't want HT equal to CT you want H you want some of the contents of CT to be masked out so you you're not seeing
it when generating the output masking would have being accounted for by fdn ID is my no because you want to keep it in CT you want there's information you want to keep in CT for the future um but you don't want visible when generating the current next word yeah um in some sense a bit I have the hardest part explaining is why is it necessarily better to have a tan H here I mean you can sort of argue that it's a way of this can just stay unbounded real numbers and then this is getting it back in the shape of stays
between zero and one which is good for the um hidden state but it's a little bit I guess they did it that way it seem to work well okay um here's another way of looking at it which may or may not be more helpful um as a picture so you know at each time step we've got you know as before um an input a hidden State and then we're going to calculate an output from that hidden state but we've sort of got this more complex computational unit and these pictures of this more complex
computational unit um were diagrams were made by Chris oler who's someone who now um right now works at anthropic um and so if you blow up in that this is sort of showing the computation so you're sort of feeding along recurrently um the C cell as the primary recurrent unit but you've also got carried along H because H is being used to calculate stuff for the next time step and then a new H is being generated um and so you're Computing the forget gate you're forgetting some of the cell content
you're Computing an input gate you're using that to compute um a potential new cell content um you write some of that into the cell um depending on the input gate um then you compute an output gate and then some of the cell will go into um the computation of H depending on the output gate and then just like for the previous recurrent new network for working out what the predicted next word is you're working out an output layer by taking the H and doing another Matrix uh plus B2 and then using a soft Max on
that to actually predict the next word okay so you know this all seems very complex um and you know back in do you have a question yeah I a so how are we deciding theold I I imagine just some sort of threshold around the probability of like what we're remembering and what we're forgetting um so you know so we we're getting more than a threshold right because we're actually we're calculating a whole Vector of forgetting and remembering so therefore it can choose to say Okay Dimensions 1 to 177 keep all
of that and throw away Dimensions 18 to 22 or really probabilistically to different extents um and so it's sort of unspecified it's up to it what it learns but we we're hoping that it will learn that certain kinds of information is useful to keep carrying forward for at least a while um but then we can use both the contents of the Hidden State and the cell sorry of the next input to decide to throw away certain information so we might think that there are certain cues for example you know if it sees the
word next it might think okay change of topic now it be a good time to forget more stuff and reset but it's sort of learning which dimensions of this Vector to hold around in an unconstrained way whatever's useful to do a better job at language modeling okay um yeah so this all looks like a very complex and contous um design and you know quite honestly um you know when teaching this around 201 you know 16 17 and this was the best kind of newal network we had for language modeling you know we
literally you know spent hours of class time um going through lstms and variant of lstms with different properties CU you know there are different ways you can do the gating you can have less Gates or more gates and do different things um and it seemed the most important thing to know um in 2024 you know it's probably not the most important thing to know um but um on lstms are um a thing to be aware of we are going to use them um for um the assignment three but you know you can just ask pytorch for an lstm and I'll
give you one that does all of this stuff but you know there is one thing that I really want to sort of focus on as to you know why what is the good thing that an lstm achieves and you know really the secret for why you get this fundamentally different behavior in an lstm is you have that plus sign right there right that for the simple recurrent neural network at each time the next hidden state was a result of multiplicative stuff and therefore it was very hard just to preserve information um whereas the essence of
the lstm is to say well look you've got this past memory of stuff you've already seen and what we want to do is add some new information to it which fundamentally seems like kind of right for human memories um that they're sort of basically additive um and when I said actually it was the second G paper that introduced a crucial part of the lstm the first version of the lstm didn't have the forget gate so it was a purely additive mechanism that you were deciding what to add to your memory as
you went along um but you know that proved to be not quite perfect because if you keep on adding more and more stuff over a long sequence that tends to be dysfunctional after a certain point and so the big Improvement was then to add this forget gate so some of it went away but nevertheless having things basically additive fixes the problem of gradient flow you no longer have um Vanishing gradients and it makes it something that seems much more memory like you're adding to the things that you
know okay um so the lstm architecture allows you to preserve information over many time sets in the cell right so if you set the forget gate to one um and the input gate to zero you're just linearly passing along in the cell indefinitely the same information okay um it's not the only way that you can do longdistance information flow and we're going to look increasingly in other in future lectures at other ways you can do um longdistance information flow um and just to sort of give a bit of a peek about those now and
to think about other architectures but there's a question no no question yes um so so since you're mentioning that those plus like hand grent uh does it help with exploding grent at all does it make it worse is there like no difference or no it also helps with exploding gradients because the fact that you're not doing this sequence of multiplies all the time that you sort of have this addition operator um so one thing you could wonder is that is Vanishing and exploding gradients just
uh Rec current neural network problem and it's not I mean it it it occurs earlier and worse when you've got long sequences but if you start building a very deep neural network surely the same thing is happening you know the parameters aren't the same so it's not quite just raising one Matrix to a power but surely depending on your matrices you tend to have the same problem that either your gradients are disappearing or else they're exploding um and that's what people found and that was part of
the reason why in the early days people weren't very successful building deep neural networks was because they suffered from problems of this sort that if you had basically Vanishing gradients um in a deep new network you got very little gradient signal in the lower layers therefore parameters didn't really update Therefore your model didn't learn anything in the lower layers therefore the network didn't work well and you know that was part of why things were stuck in the days around the
early 2000s of deep networks didn't work um and so there are other ways you can think about fixing that so one common way of fixing that is to add more direct connection so you know the problem when we went through our um current step was we were sort of had this in between stuff of doing a matrix multiply and bl blah blah blah um and that kind of caused indirectness and the possibility for things to either explode or vanish um so this network is written sort of upside down when I stole the picture
from the paper so we'll just have to deal with that like um right so the in we're going downwards from here to the next layer so you know rather than going through sort of weight layers and weight layers which will start to produce the same kind of problems what you can do is sort of apply the same trick in a vertical Network and say well look I can also just carry the input around with an identity function and add it on here and so then I've got this sort of direct carrying of information and so that um
led to the residual Network which was what completely transformed computer vision models um and made them much more learnable um than pure networks that lack these residual connections um if you sort of start heading down that path you can think well why only provide these residual Loops that take you one step maybe I could directly connect each layer to all the successive layers and so people played with that idea and that led to the so-called dens net where you have these kind of skip connections linking
to every other layer um a variant of the residual Network the res net um which was actually again introduced by schmidhuber and students was to say well rather than just directly adding in the input um summed with the output of the new network layer maybe again we'd be better better off having gating so that you are deciding by Gates how much of the input to have skip around and so that led to a variant um the the highway net um where you've got sort of GED residual networks so various ideas of doing that um not
going to say more about that right now I want to skip ahead and sort of do the rest of new or Nets and get on to um machine translation okay um so once you have rnns where RNN is including lstms normally in practice lstms you can use them for anything else where you're doing sequences and so there are lots of places they're used in N so if you want to assign words parts of speech like nouns and verbs that would be commonly done with a part of speech tagging lstm if you want to be assigning named entity labels like
location right I I did this toy version where we were signing a label to the middle of a window but you want to assign a label at each position you can use an lstm for named entity recognition you can use an RNN as a encoder model for a whole sentence so if we want to do sentiment classifications see whether a piece of text is positive or negative um we can say run an lstm over it and then use this as a representation of the sentence to in work out whether it's positive or negative piece of text and
well the simplest way of doing that is to use the final hidden State because after all that final hidden state is the hidden State you've gotten from having seen the entire sentence and use that and then have a sort of a classification layer um logistic regression on top of that to give you positive or negative in practice though people have found it's often better to use every hidden State and take some kind of mean or elementwise Max and feed that in as the sentence encoding you can also use rnns for lots
of other purposes where you're using it to generate text based on other information so if you want to do speech recognition or summarization machine translation um that we'll come to later you can have an an input source which you'll use to condition your network and then you'll generate the speech recognition or the um machine translation as we'll see later and so we refer to those as conditional language models because rather than just generating text starting from nothing
from a start token we're generating it conditioned on some source of information um one other idea on what normally happens when people use these um you know I suggested um that you know we could sort of do this averaging at each position if you think of these about these hidden State representations these hidden State representations that representation isn't only about the word terribly it has some information about what came before it the movie was terribly but it has no information about what comes
after it and well you might think you'd like to have a representation of terribly that knows what came before it but also what came after it and so people sort of came up with the next obvious idea to deal with that which was to build a bidirectional lstm so you ran a Ford lstm and then you start another lsdm that's shown in that sort of greenish teal and you ran it backwards and so then you had a forwards and backwards Vector at each position and you just concatenated them both and then you had
a two-sided context for a representation of word meaning and so these networks um were pretty widely used so um we were sort of running a forward RNN a backward RNN and concatenating the states together and those were then sort of commonly sort of written like this to suggest that in a compact way you're running a bidirectional RNN um that and you know these were very popular for language analysis they're not they weren't working able if you wanting to generate text um but you using them in a
lot of places as a representation but more recently Transformer models have normally taken over from that um one more idea which we'll see for machine translation is um you know rnns are sort of deep in the sense that they unroll over many time steps but up until now they've only been shallow rnns in the sense that we just had one hidden state but you can also make them Deep by having multiple layers of hidden States what was also commonly called stacked rnns so you'd have several layers of
rnns um built above each other and you might wonder H does this really do anything is it are they just big vectors above the words but precisely because you have sort of this extra newal Network layer between here and here here you get exactly the same power Advantage you get otherwise with newal networks that you can do successive layers of feature extraction and so you get more power out of your neural network um to some extent um what people yeah I okay to some extent what people um found with new rnns in those days um is
the having multiple layers definitely helps but unlike what was happening in those days with other kinds of newal networks for vision Etc people still use relatively shallow shallow RNN so you know you always got a lot of gains by having two layers rather than one but you know commonly it started to be more iffy whether you got extra value from three or four layers so commonly people were running two or thre layer lstms and that's what people were using but that's completely changed around in
the world of Transformers um where nowadays people are building very deep um Transformer networks for doing language understanding okay but I Should Skip ahead and say a few words before time runs out about machine translation um so machine translation is one of the key natural language processing tasks where We're translating um words from sentences in one language to sentences in another language so we're starting off um with a sentence in some language here French and what we want to do is output it in a different
language here English um so that machine translation was actually where NLP started right so in the early 50s there wasn't artificial intelligence yet there wasn't a field of NLP yet um but people started to work on machine translation um and the story of why people started to work on machine translation was essentially you know computers were first developed um during the second world war and during the second world war computers were used for two things one of them was calculating artillery table targets artillery tables
to sort of work out what angle to put your gun on to get it to land in the right place I'm not very relevant to what we're doing but the other thing the other thing that computers were used for was code breaking um so um after the second world war it moved very quickly into the cold war and there were you know concerns on both sides um you know of keeping up with the science that was being developed on both sides and people had the idea of gee maybe we could think of translation between languages as like
code breaking and that thought um occurred to um important relevant people and science funding agencies and actually lots and lots of funding was poured into this idea of can we use computers to do machine translation between languages and you know at the time in the 50s you know after some initial very impressive looking cook demos it was sort of basically a complete flop and the reason you know there are lots of reasons why it's was a complete flop you know one was people knew almost nothing about the structure
of human languages I mean in particular when I was mentioning the other day the Chomsky hierarchy right and knowing about sort of context free languages right the chompsky hierarchy even hadn't been invented yet right sort of formal properties of languages hadn't being explored but also you know the computers um that people had in the 1950s right the amount of P computing power or memory or anything like this that those computers had in those days was laughable right these days you know the
little power brick for your laptop has more computing power inside it than the big mainframe computers that they used to be using in those days so um basically um people were only able to build very simple lexicons and rule-based substitution rules and nothing like the complexity of human languages which only gradually people began to understand um but machine translation started to become more alive in the 1990s and 2000s decades once people started to build empirical models over lots of data and the approach then
was called statistical machine translation and so when Google translate was first introduced to the world um it was sort of the big unveiling to the world of statistical phrase-based machine translation systems where what you were doing was you were collecting a large amount of parallel data words that have been translated from one word to another and you know not for all languages but for quite a few languages quite a few sources of parallel data so the European Union generates a huge amount of parallel data
among European languages there are places like Hong Kong where you get English Chinese if a certain dialect of Chinese um parallel data um the UN generates a lot of parallel data so getting sources of parallel data and trying to build models and so the way it was done was based on that model we're going to try and learn uh probability model for translation so this um the probability of a translation given a source sentence and the way it was done at that time was breaking it down using Bas rule into two um sub problems so the
probability of the translation given the source is going to be the inverted probability of the source given the translation times the probability of the translation and and you know you could think that this makes it no simpler because you've just you know reversed the order of X and Y but the reason why it made it simpler and people were able to make progress was the translation model was treated as a very simple model as to how words tended to get translated to words in the other language and it
didn't need to know anything about you know word order grammar structure of the other Lang anguage and then all of that was being handled by just this probability of why which was a pure language model as we've talked about before so you could have a simple translation model which just sort of said you know if you see the word om in French you might want to translate it as man or person or and put some probabilities on that and then most of the cleverness was in the language model which was telling you what would be a
good sentence in the target language okay um and so that was important because you know translations get pretty complicated right so um you not only have to know how to translate words and those translations of words VAR in context um but you get a lot of reordering of words in sentences um I'm not going to be able to spend a lot of time on this but you know here here for a while um was my favorite example machine translation sentence um so um this is actually a translated sentence so it comes the original comes from the book
Guns Germs and Steel if you're familiar with that um but it was that book by Jared Diamond um but this book was um translated into Chinese so here's a sentence um from um the book in Chinese and you know uh I guess in the 2000th decade I was involved in building statistical machine translation systems and I guess there was a Mt evaluation um that um we did where our system did terribly on this sentence and I tried it out on Google translate and it also did terribly in this sentence so what the sentence should say is in 1519
600 Spaniards landed in Mexico to conquer the Aztec empire with a population of a few million they lost 2/3 of their soldiers in the initial Clash um so here's what Google translate said in 2019 2009 1519 600 Spaniards landed in Mexico millions of people to conquer the Aztec empire the first 2third of soldiers against their loss um now it's partly bad because the word choices in the translations very good um but you know it's especially bad because it's just um not actually able to capture and use the
modification relationships um of the sentence so you know here's the part of the Chinese that's saying the Aztec Empire and over there in Orange is the few million people and in Chinese there's this explicit little character here dur which is saying that stuff in Orange modifies this stuff in green which is what it's meant to be in the correct translation of Aztec empire with a population of a few million um but Google translate completely fails on that and it's Suddenly It's the millions
of people who are going to be conquering um the Aztec empire um and you know that's sort of in this way um the worst thing that's happening here though you know the 151 19600 isn't exactly a very good translation um and the first 2third of soldiers against their loss isn't very good either um but you know so for a while I used to sort of update this and see what happened you know um in 2013 it almost seemed like progress had been made but by 2015 it had gone downhill back to how it
was before so it just seemed like they got lucky in 2013 rather than the systems were working any better um and indeed this sort of seemed to be the problem although some kind of progress had been made in machine translation um these systems um just you know sort of never really worked all that great um and so that led to this amazing breakthrough in 2014 um where we then moved to neural machine translation and new machine translation was much better so what did we do in neural machine translation so
we built a neural machine translation system as a single endtoend neural network and that's been a powerful idea in newal network systems in general including in NLP if we can just have a single big system and put a loss function at the end of it and then we can back propagate errors right back down through the system um it means we're sort of aligning all of our learning for the final task we want to do and that's been very effective whereas earlier models couldn't do that um so we built it with a sequence to
sequence model so that sounds like our lstms but it's meaning that we're going to have two of them one of them to encode the sentence um The Source sentence and one to produce the target sentence so that's what we're building so for the Source sentence we're taking here it says RNN but let's just think lstm because that's what we're going to use in practice it's much better and so we're going to chunk through it encoding um what we've read using an RNN
so this RNN isn't going to Output anything right we're just building up a hidden state that knows what's in the source sentence um so again encoding of the source sentence and we're going to use that final hidden state to condition the decoder RNN which is going to then generate the translation so for the decoder RNN it's also an lstm but it's going to be an lstm with different parameters so we're going to be learning one set one lstm with Source en coding parameters and then for the different
language we're learning a different lstm that all know about the target language and so we give it start and say well feed in for feed in your past what you've encoded from the encoder RNN as your starting point um and then we're going to be I that'll be count as the previous hidden State you're feeding into your um lstm and then we're going to generate the first word of the translation and we'll then copy that translated word down using this as a generative model as I did last time and
we um start translating through he hit me with a pie okay um so does that sort of make sense the model yeah okay um so okay there's some note sorry um yeah sorry what I was going to say yeah so the the little pink note here so what I was showing you is the picture of using it at sort of runtime at run time we're going to encode the source and then generate the words of the translation at training time we're going to have parallel text we're going to have sentences in their translations
we're going to run with the same architecture but as before then for the decoder Network we're going to try and predict each word and then say what probability did you assign the actual next word and that will give us a loss and we'll be calculating the losses at each position working out the average loss working out the gradients back propagating them through the entire network both the decoder RNN and the encoder RNN networks and updating all the parameters of our model and that's
the sense in which it's being trained end to end okay um so sequence so this is sort of a general notion of an encoder decoder model which is a very general thing that we use in all kinds of places right that we have one network that encod something which produces a representation which will then feed into another Network that we'll use to decode something and even when we go on to do other things like use Transformers rather than lstms we're still commonly going to use these kind of encoded ecoda
models because if we want to do not only machine translation but other tasks um like um summarization or um text to speech or other things like that we're going to be in this space of using encoder decoder networks yeah what is the difference between this encod de model and just using a deeper neural network with more layers um well a lot is sequenced um right so it has never been very Su you're meaning like why don't you just build on top of the source right um people have tried that occasionally it's never been very
successful and I think part of the reason is all of what I was trying to show before about all all of the word order changes around a lot between languages and if you're sort of um just trying to build stuff on top of the source sentence it's very hard to cope with that in particular it's not even the case that the length stays the same right one of the big ways um in which languages vary is what little words that they have right so that in English you're putting in a lot of these
auxiliary verbs and articles whereas it's in Chinese you don't have any of those and so you're neither needing to depending on Direction add a lot of words or subtract a lot of words which is very hard to do if you're sort of building on top of the source of it ah is it quick uh yeah so left side is that b directional or just like a like the encoder um yeah so you you totally think and it could be that the encoder is bidirectional and that might be better um for the for the famous
original instantiation of this that was done at Google they actually didn't make it bir directional so it was simply taking the final hidden state but that's absolutely an alternative that you could do okay okay um yeah so I sort of said it was um okay usable for lots of things okay um yeah so this is our um conditional language model um this so we're now kind of directly calculating the probability of Y given X right that the decoder model is generating um uh language expression as a language model directly conditioned
on X um and so we train it with a big parallel Corpus um and that's the only case I'm going to talk about today recently there's been sort of some interesting work on unsupervised machine translation meaning that you're got only a little bit of information about how the languages relate you don't really have a lot of parallel text but I'm not going to cover that today um yeah so for training it we have um paired sentences um we work out our losses in the predictions at each position and then
we're working out our average loss and back propagating it through in a single system end to end as described um yeah so in practice um when people built Big Machine translation systems this was one of the places where absolutely it gave value to have multi- layer stacked um lstms and so typically people are building a model there and you'll be building a model something like this that's a multi-layer lstm that's being used to encode and decode um in my two minutes um remaining um I
just want to sort of um quickly say so um building these new machine translation systems was really the first big success of natural language processing deep learning now in this in this sense you know it depends on how you define what parts of language if you look at the sort of the history of the Renaissance of deep learning the first place where deep learning was highly successful was in speech recognition systems um the second place in which it was highly successful was then object recognition
and vision and then the third place that was highly successful was then building machine translation systems um so you know Google had a big um statistical machine translation system and it was uh it was only in 2014 that people first built this sort of lstm um deep learning machine translation system but it was just sort of obviously super good and it was so super good that in only two 2 years it was then deployed as the live system um that was being used at Google but it wasn't only used in Google um that new
machine translation was just so much better than what had come before that by a couple of years after that you know absolutely everybody um both us companies and Chinese companies Microsoft Facebook 10cent bu um everybody was using new machine translation system because they are just much better systems and so this was an amazing success right CU um statistical machine translation systems like the Google system that this is something that had been worked on for about a decade hundreds of people had worked on
it there were millions of lines of code lots of hacks built in um for particular languages and language pairs um but really a simple small um newal machine translation system was able to um work much better um there was an article published about it when it sort went live in the New York Times that you can find in that um link it's a um a little bit of a a praising piece um where you could be a little bit critical um but you know basically it's sort of talking about how just the difference in quality
was so obvious that everyone immediately noticed even before Google had announced it of w some Machine translation's gone so much better okay um so that's basically today so um for today you know we've leared that lstms are powerful if you're doing something with a current new network you probably want to use an lstm um you should know about the idea of clipping your gradients um bidirectional lstms are good when you've got an encoder but you can't use them to generate new text
um and encoder decoder rual machine translation systems were great new technology um that advanced the field thank you